i want to pull up this story we have
here from the hill
biden says if medical team advises it
he'll issue domestic travel vaccine
requirement now joe biden is elected
but this what you're you were just
talking about how there's unelected you
know bureaucrats i think another issue
here is that there's
rule by edict
so it with these with these vaccine
mandates in new york it's it's it's an
executive who just says i'm going to do
it without approval of the courts
without the legislature
legislative body this is what we're
getting now across the board people like
biden
threatening domestic travel requirement
or
domestic travel vaccine mandates they're
basically saying we're going to do this
anyway
and then it will get a good three months
before the courts actually intervene and
do anything about it so it's rule by
decree aside from you know like the
senate parliamentarian and other issues
we are just continually getting
governors mayors and the president doing
whatever they want and there seems to be
no recourse or um opportunity for a
redress of grievances
fauci just came out and said it the
other night he was just like look if it
basically gets more people vaccinated
then it's a good thing at the end of the
day yeah he admitted the mandates are
just kind of of a way to manipulate
people to get vaccinated totally against
the nuremberg code exactly instantly but
he said it out loud he said it was a
mechanism it was just it's a mechanism
it's not for your safety it's not for
your health it's not for your well-being
it's not for you to look out it's for
you to buy a product not not a violation
of the nuremberg code no no no no that's
not true
the nuremberg code that people are
referring to states that you have to
consent to participate in a trial study
and so the argument is that because
they're still doing long-term trials on
the vaccine no one no one's consent
you're literally literally consenting to
it the the i understand the vaccine
mandates basically are coercing people
into doing it so that's that's the gray
area i just want to clarify i suppose
when you have an emergency use
authorized authorization for a vaccine
it's not in the same territory as
putting a human being in a laboratory
setting and then you know what i mean
that's what i'm trying to clarify
well the argument that i heard is that
coercion is a strike against that
because if you're coercing people to
participate in that kind of environment
then it's also against the nuremberg
code because that is coercion yeah if
you can't travel and you have to get
this forced shot then that's coercion to
participate in a medical experiment you
know what i'm gonna i'm gonna go ahead
and say uh i said corrected on that one
you know why first i'm not a lawyer so i
can't tell you what if it actually does
violent number of code but i'm gonna
walk that back and and just say actually
you know what that's a that's a good
point the issue is that people uh
so long as there is phase i think it's
phase two what what phase are we on
they're doing long term trials right now
actually says this on the fda insert
phase two i believe we're in right now
so there's no we've done fantasy yeah
yeah we're past that so phase one is
safety phase two is efficacy yeah those
were the trials that have been completed
with a hundred thousand people or more
the the the fda insert for the pfizer
vaccine says long-term studies are still
being done
so
you're gonna get people on the left
saying it's eua authorized it's already
gone through the safety trials so it
doesn't qualify in that capacity people
on the right are saying well as long as
they are doing studies on it i actually
i don't know man i kind of lean towards
i don't think i think it's a bit
hyperbolic to say it violates the
nuremberg code
yeah i don't know man
this is all it's look i'll put it this
way
the the hype we are we are polarized we
are completely polarized there's there's
different world views on what what is
happening
i'll just put it this way the left will
say it's eua authorized the studies have
said it's safe therefore and the right's
going to be like they're they're not
they haven't finished long-term studies
therefore well the new york times came
out with a bombshell article today
talking about how some scientists are
warning that too many shots could lead
to people's uh bodies not being able to
fight off covet that's not me saying it
that's the new york times that literally
wrote a piece about this which which
again is breaking the narrative of what
we were previously told and and and
believed to by the medical let me let me
just advisors pull that one up just to
show you we new york times is struggling
to load and the byline is specifically
the most important part here um that
that people really need to to read and
to think about especially in the context
of everything that we were told
so what what uh which spec
go to the bind
i got it right here look look look it
says other experts argued that not
enough was known about the effects of a
fourth shot and some scientists have
raised concerns that too many shots
might cause a sort of immune system
fatigue compromising the body's ability
to fight the virus particularly among
older people this is the new york times
reporting so i want to wrap it back up
to what you were saying about nuremberg
if we don't know
and they're already a point are at the
point where several countries have said
a fourth shot from you know compromised
i mean now i think you're getting into
you're you're starting to get a
dangerous territory over what what over
what you're going to mandate people uh
get so the okay so from my understanding
from what i've just learned about the
nuremberg argument part of the argument
is based on the definition of coercion
is that not correct from mind that's
what i've heard yeah so if you're gonna
say that you can't oh you can't travel
you can't shop you can't go to you know
the gym you can't go to movies that
sounds like coercion to me but you i
guess you would have to look up the
definition and make sure that you're
arguing on the same terms i think you
could literally if that was the
definition of you would you would be
able to apply that to virtually like any
approved drug that's interesting i i i
don't think the
exactly this kind of article right in
the new york times
this is assuming that people are adults
and that they're that this is a novel
virus that there are risks involved with
it that like this is treating people as
adults and the problem is that a lot of
our public health institutions have not
given people straight information they
have given people a narrative to try to
manipulate them into behaving the way
that they want at any given time and
that that way changes right we saw like
the the changes over time with regard to
max masks right um with regard to a
thousand other issues i think that the
problem is that we have not treated
people as adults and sure some people
are irresponsible um but that that's
kind of the price of freedom in this
country is that there are
you know people get to behave
irresponsibly sometimes um but i i i
think the problem is we have not treated
again we have not treated american
citizens as adults we've been treated as
pawns to try to like influence people
instead of just saying straight out
here's the information we have it may
change because this is a new virus
this is you know here's the
recommendations that we're giving
because you know we are studying this as
experts and scientists but the problem
is the entire premise of trust for the
expertise and and um that entire class
of of quote unquote experts and
managerial class is shot you know what
let's just be really i just want to add
to you that wasn't a pun but they
haven't they haven't leveled with us
they haven't came out saying hey we
don't know the data we don't know the
information we're still collecting it
this is the informed consent that you
guys are taking here there's also it's
and it's surprising to see the new york
times release this article because
it is it is important there are a lot of
implications with those statements and
there's also a new york times editor
that died uh recently of a heart attack
that a lot of people have questions
surrounding so so this could be kind of
you know potentially in the new york
times deciding to ask more questions
after dealing with stuff and yeah but
but look
we use
mainstream news sources in a lot of our
reporting and
all the information that we have save
like project veritas is despised by the
media but i trust uh project veritas but
almost i would say every single article
we use save like one or two is newsguard
certified you know established press and
and the information we get that that
talks about this stuff it always comes
from these sources you know when we we
get an article about people being
arrested in burger king by nypd it's
it's the new york post when we get
stories about hunter biden it's coming
from the new york post we got a story
about um a ukrainian court saying that
ukrainians were meddling in the election
and that was the new york times that
wrote that yeah you've got to weed
through the garbage from these sources
but my point is like you can find those
the like the news and this and and we we
use it so i don't want to i don't i'm
i'm just trying to say like i'm not
surprised the new york times wrote about
this you know it just depends on who's
writing about it i guess but here's what
i do i do want to say
you know we're talking about the
nuremberg code and stuff and i feel like
that's a d that's that's that's probably
a derailment we don't even we don't even
need to bring that up we don't need to
argue about whether or not it's a
violation of some long-standing you know
code or law what matters is coercing
people into a medical practice is wrong
period i don't care for what reason i
believe that if if you walk up to
somebody you can see they got a swollen
knee and you're like you know what this
person needs they need methyl
prednisolone is that is that what they
would give for us for a
methylprednosillone yeah what is that
not sure i think it's oxycontin
they're probably going to give you that
steroid no i don't know all right
google it for me yeah look it up uh if
if you see somebody and you're like
you've got a swollen joint and you need
some kind of steroid to to you know
anti-inflammatory uh for this and they
say no i say okay
yep that that treats uh inflammation
severe allergies players of chronic
illnesses and many other medical
problems you see i was correct you were
correct so if i go up to somebody who's
got like a busted knee and i say you
know you should the doctor prescribes it
not me take this methyl presence alone
and they say i choose not to well then
they can say okay but if you go nuh your
knees busted no food for you no movies
no restaurants no flying okay
that's where it's like let's not get
into the weeds on the the weird murky
political stuff about nuremberg or
whatever because we can just outright
say it don't coerce people into taking
medications or if you're obese like
imagine if you're obese or have an std
imagine implementing the same
restrictions on individuals for those
lifestyle choices i mean yeah i don't
envision a society like that sorry go
ahead no no so to me i think the
distinction then has to be and i don't
think you can avoid the whole discussion
that way because the distinction has to
be things that injure yourself versus
others right and
now especially in the last several
months it's become very very clear that
vaccinated people can pass this virus
and to me that makes the argument for
the other side much much weaker
because
at the end of the day i'm i'm very
pro-vaccine i have my vaccines but i
think that at the end of the day if it's
not reducing transmission by any
substantial degree anymore then it
becomes about
it's like it's like you know you're only
hurting yourself you're only taking your
chances yourself it's no longer an
aspect of actually affecting anyone else
because it seems very very clear at this
point that you are not preventing other
people from getting coveted by being
vaccinated what you're doing is making a
decision about your own risk which is
ultimately an individual decision they
would have to say testing mandates
because
if you get vaccinated and you can still
get it and people are like you you were
saying before the show that people in
new york all have omicron like it's it's
record-breaking there's like 50 000
cases or whatever and it's bad i mean
you said people are like flat on their
back like bad i'm sick yeah i mean it's
like a bad flu i mean i i just got over
it um
i i caught it at a dinner party um happy
birthday to me it's my dinner
but uh you know all seven people there
uh were vaccinated every single person
was exposed the only person who didn't
catch it fortunately or at least only
had the sniffles one person who was the
most medically fragile so i'm really
really glad that he did not but
everybody else like everybody else got
sick it's very very clear that this is
not stopping it
so there's no justification now there's
there has to be i think there has to be
some balance between if you're affecting
other people this is sort of a
negotiation of a liberal democracy how
much you know the negotiation between
the individual and and the common good
happens um but there is no negotiation
anymore to my mind if you if you are not
reducing uh the the infection rate in
the general population by being
vaccinated there is no argument we've
been hearing a bit in the media that
it's uh milder and there's been there
was one story one viral story saying
it's like runny noses but you were
saying it's actually worse than that
like luke brought it up earlier he said
it's like it's like mild and then you
said well i had friends who had it who
just described it as a kind of runny
nose just like a cloa like a cold uh but
that's my experiences your experiences
are of course different yeah i that's
not what i've seen in new york city but
obviously that's anecdotal um but i i
think but worst thing
yeah like like flu like bad flu most
people i know who caught it it's a week
or two in bed you know high fever uh
feeling miserable this is just anecdotal
though i don't you know i can't right
right i can't like i just i i just
thought that was interesting because uh
before the show you know luke had
mentioned it every anecdotal
story i've heard on like twitter is like
these people are saying i'm triple faxed
and i was floored by this
and then i see people posting you know
images from news stories where it's like
it's not that bad it's mild or whatever
i i i look i don't know what we had i
i'm assuming we had delta when it came
here worst sickness i've ever had do you
know i didn't feel like i didn't think i
was like my life was on the verge of
dying i thought i was in the hospital to
be honest though yeah you were in a very
serious
as well um i was taking different stuff
but that's a different story do you know
do you know if your friends uh
were specifically tested for a variant
or d do they know which variable i mean
at the time it's pretty clear what's
circulating in new york city um it's and
it's also the fact that uh there was
still some transmission protection with
delta um and the fact that like every
person that it has uh either two or
three shots is catching this makes it
seem much more likely that it's omicron
well yeah well new york city is one of
the most vaccinated places in the world
and on december 26th they had almost 25
percent of all cases in the united
states presented and in south africa
there's also a lot of preliminary data
suggesting that this new omnicron
variant is getting rid of the delta
variant and is creating a lot of people
to have natural immunity and then a lot
of people are reporting that south
africa is on up and up right now and
that they have reduced a lot of
hospitalizations a lot of admissions a
lot of debts have fallen off completely
in that country
i think we're going to see
a spike in the next few weeks in
hospitalizations even if it's much
milder which i actually do believe
um you know i think some of the data the
data from south africa is not
particularly helpful for the united
states because we are older fatter um
and we have a totally different
percentage of vaccinated people and uh
so yeah south africa has very little
value right very little vaccination so
the data that's coming in from the uk i
think is probably more relevant to us
and and there seems to be good reason to
think this is substantially milder and
it's resulting in a smaller percentage
of people going to the hospital or dying
but a smaller percentage of a very very
large number if you are having 20 000
cases recorded a day
which means that the actual caseload is
much higher than that right you're still
going to see
probably an increase in hospitalizations
i hope not but i think i think you're
right though i think after this
a lot of people will have natural
immunity which is something that
is for some reason only america doesn't
talk about natural immunity european
countries consider like it's part of the
policy calculation israel keeps it as
part of the policy calculation um
there's there's no reason other than
bias and ideology as far as i can tell
that natural immunity is not part of the
conversation no talking about early
treatment as well which is ridiculous
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you